mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir le conseil des ministres a
adopté ce matin le projet de loi sur
l'interruption de la grossesse tel qu'il
avait été préparé par le ministre de la
santé monsieur giscard d'estaing a
estimé que ce projet répondait avec
humanité et lucidité aux problèmes posés
ce sont naturellement les parlementaires
qui auront le dernier mot
le projet sera examiné par l'assemblée
nationale le 26 novembre
le problème c'est de remplacer la
législation de 1920 et 1923 sur
l'avortement qui n'est plus du tout
appliqué aujourd'hui déjà le
gouvernement de monsieur messmer avait
proposé un projet de loi l'année
dernière pour modifier cette législation
c'était une libéralisation importante
l'interruption de la grossesse aurait
été permise quand elle présentait un
danger immédiat au lointain pour la
santé physique psychique ou mentale de
la mère en cas de risque de
malformations du foetus et lorsque la
grossesse était la conséquence d'un acte
de violence ou criminelle après un débat
mouvementé de deux jours à l'assemblée
nationale le projet de monsieur
poniatowski à leur ministre de la santé
était repoussé le 14 décembre dernier
par 255 voix contre 212 le nouveau
projet présenté par madame veil est
adoptée aujourd'hui par le conseil des
ministres est beaucoup plus libéral
s'il est adopté avant la dixième semaine
de la grossesse l'interruption seraient
autorisés mais elles seraient soumises à
des précautions pour protéger la femme
l'intervention devrait obligatoirement
être faite par un médecin et en milieu
hospitalier c'est-à-dire soit dans un
hôpital soit dans une clinique
elles ne seraient pas remboursés par la
sécurité sociale après la 10e semaine
l'interruption de la grossesse ne sera
autorisée que dans les cas exceptionnels
c'est-à-dire lorsque cette grossesse
présente un péril grave pour la santé de
la mère et des risques élevé
d'affections graves pour l'enfant il
s'agit alors d'un avortement
thérapeutique qui exige la vie de deux
médecins dont un est agréé par la cour
d'appel
je pense que la situation actuellement
est une situation injuste est mauvaise
elle est injuste pour les femmes parce
qu'en définitive c'est surtout
entre les plus démunis les plus
défavorisés que la loi pénale
actuellement et rigoureuse pour les
autres il est très facile d'aller
rowland est très facile d'aller en
angleterre et même quelquefois aussi
facile de trouver un médecin qui fasse
en france il y en a nous savons mais en
revanche pour les femmes qui sont plus
perdus les moins informés qu'ils n'ont
pas d'argent qui sont perdus soit dans
leur campagne soit même dans des
conditions de vie très difficiles dans
les îles elles ne savent pas comment
faire quand elles vous attendent un
enfant qu'elles ne peuvent vraiment pas
assumer alors c'est pour ça qu'on trouve
la situation est mauvaise et que nous
cessons souhaitable de la modifier parce
qu'il ya trop de femmes actuellement
tiendront une grossesse dans des
conditions pénibles
ce ne sera pas remboursé par la sécurité
sociale le texte ne précise rien en
matière de sécurité sociale donc on se
retrouve dans le droit commun
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
acte médical qui a une raison
thérapeutique comme l'avortement
thérapeutique qui est autorisé par le
texte la sécurité sociale remboursera
lorsqu au contraire il ne s'agira pas
d'un acte médical
la sécurité sociale est conforme à ce
que vous ne craignez pas que ça remplace
un peu la contraception
j'espère bien que non seulement bien sûr
il faut du temps pour que la
contraception dans les murs
vous savez qu'elle n'a été autorisée que
depuis 1967 que ce n'est que la loi qui
est actuellement entre enfin le projet
de loi qui est actuellement en cours de
discussion devant le parlement qui
permet de faire une large information
est pour l'instant trop de femmes en
fait ne savent pas très bien qu'elles
peuvent aller voir un médecin qu'elles
peuvent pas obtenir une ordonnance soit
pour se faire poser un stérilet soit
pour acheter des contraceptifs oraux ce
qui fait que elles n'ont pas encore pris
l'habitude de la contraception et c'est
pour ça qu'il est encore temps
d'avortements clandestins
est ce pour cela que législateur est
obligé d'intervenir et d'ailleurs le
projet de loi précise de façon
rigoureuse que le en cas d'interruption
de grossesse la femme devra être devra
être obligatoirement informé des
méthodes contraceptives
nous espérons en tout cas si elle a
recours à l'avortement ce ne sera qu on
soit à plusieurs s'ils ne venaient pas
voter qu'est ce qui va se passer
alors on restera dans la situation après
c'est à dire une situation d'une loi
inapplicable qui n'est pas appliqué ce
problème de l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse est un problème grave
puisqu'il touche à la conscience de
chacun et de chaque et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le prix de la république à
la fin du débat du conseil des ministres
a tenu ce matin à faire une déclaration
que je voudrais ici sites tels sont les
motifs qui ont conduit le gouvernement à
établir à projets mettant fin à une
situation de désordre et d'injustice et
apportant une solution mesurer et
humaines à l'un des problèmes les plus
difficiles de notre temps je cite les
problèmes ce problème qui continuera à
poser à chaque individu la question
graves et douloureuses des
responsabilités qu'ils exercent
vis-à-vis de la vie est d'autant qu'un
texte législatif du permettra jamais de
ce décès ce projet de loi sera discuté à
l'assemblée nationale à partir du 26
novembre prochain